[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes aujourd'hui avec le
secrétaire général de l'organisation du
traité de sécurité collective
stanislas das monsieur à ce beau jour le
7 octobre c'était le 18e anniversaire de
la signature de la charte de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective au tc le même jour le
ministère des affaires étrangères de la
fédération de russie à organiser une
table ronde dans le cadre des journées
de l'hôte et c'est au cours de laquelle
a été dressé le bilan des activités de
l'organisation au cours de toutes ces
années la stratégie de développement de
l'hôtesse et a été évoquée a parlé nous
s'il vous plaît des thèmes évoqués ce
jour-là et expliquez nous ce que
l'organisation représente aujourd'hui
son rôle son objectif ses capacités et
sa place dans le système de sécurité
internationale
effectivement le 7 octobre quelque chose
de très intéressant a eu lieu une table
ronde à l'initiative du ministère des
affaires étrangères de la fédération de
russie elle coïncidait avec
l'anniversaire de la signature de la
charte de l'eau tsc en 2002 dans la
ville de pishin est en fait l'accent n'a
pas été mis sur les résultats des
activités de l'organisation c'est
toujours un sujet distincts dans nos
conversations nous nous sommes
concentrés sur les perspectives de
développement de l'ôter c'est le thème
était formulée ainsi repères stratégique
pour le développement de l'hôtel bien
sûr il est nécessaire d'examiner les
perspectives de développement en
relation avec les données de base tels
que l'état de l'organisation la
situation actuellement en développement
dans notre zone de responsabilité et
dans le monde en général
nous avons donc évaluer les choses ainsi
où nous en sommes dans quelle situation
nous travaillons et dans ce contexte
nous discutons des repères et
perspectives de développement qu'est ce
que représente le tc aujourd'hui oui
nous avons également parlé de cela et si
nous résumons les déclarations qui ont
été faites nous
dire que selon une opinion commune
l'hôte est assez est aujourd'hui une
organisation internationale qui a fait
ses preuves malgré sa relative jeunesse
à l'échelle humaine à l'âge de la
majorité
c'est une très courte période pour une
structure internationale comme mais
pourquoi on arrive on nous à une telle
conclusion
parce que trois tâche très importante
pour l'existence de l'organisation pour
toute organisation internationale en
fait ont été effectués
premièrement le cadre juridique et
réglementaire nécessaire à la résolution
des problèmes auxquels l'organisation
est confrontée a été établi cette base a
été mise en place et elle nous permet de
fonctionner dans le contexte actuel mais
bien sûr cela ne signifie pas qu'il faut
y mettre un point final la situation
change évolue d'autres actions sont
nécessaires la transformation est
constante mais la base elle rire de ce
qu'elle dit est épatant deuxièmement les
organes de travail ont été créés leur
manière de travailler a été élaboré leur
fonctionnement est érodé les
troisièmement les forces et moyens
nécessaires y compris les forces
défensives collectives ont été créés
leur formation et leur soutien ont été
organisées
ce sont les objectifs ont été réalisés
au cours de cette période ce qui permet
de conclure que l'organisation a fait
ses preuves
en outre l'organisation est reconnue au
niveau international y compris par l'onu
vous savez sans doute que l'assemblée
générale des nations unies a eu lieu en
septembre se tienne 6 2 mais ça sonne le
jour même de son ouverture une
déclaration conjointe du secrétaire
général de l'onu et du secrétaire
général de l'hôtesse et a été publiée
dans laquelle nous avons évalué de
manière positive nos interactions et
déclaré que nous continuerions à
renforcer cette coopération nous
coopérons également avec l'eau et celle
là c'est vil ocs et d'autres
organisations internationales comme la
croix rouge
tout cela montre que notre organisation
est reconnu dans le monde
de plus elle résout véritablement les
problèmes qui peuvent se poser et elle
agit face à des menaces qui concerne
tout le monde
comme la lutte contre le terrorisme il
ne s'agit pas là d'exercice mais des
réelles mission la lutte contre les
stupéfiants contre la migration illégale
contre le mercenariat et elle s'occupe
aussi de certains problèmes
informationnel voilà pour ce qui est de
nos repères stratégique nos voies de
développement et l'état de notre
organisation
quels sont les objectifs de
l'organisation c'est ils n'ont pas
changé au fil des ans ils sont restés
tels qu'ils ont été établi en 2002 dans
sa charte
nous n'avons qu'un seul du tout ils sont
plutôt qu'il est double il s'agit de
consolider la paix la sécurité
internationales et régionales et de
protéger collectivement la souveraineté
l'indépendance et l'intégrité
territoriale de nos états tout en
donnant la priorité aux moyens
politiques
c'est ce qui est inscrit presque
littéralement dans notre charte et nous
ne nous désengageons pas de ses
objectifs
récemment j'ai vu quelque part dans des
médias un reproche adressé à l'eau tsc
selon lequel l'organisation serait
fictives
parce qu'elle n'a combattu nulle part
qu'elle n'a pas fait ses preuves mais de
quoi parle-t-on
si l'organisation combattaient cela
voudrait dire qu'elle n'a pas rempli son
rôle principal qui consiste à protéger
la paix et à renforcer la sécurité
peut-être que c'est la réalisation la
plus importante de notre organisation
on a pu éviter des guerres et des
conflits dans notre zone de
responsabilité et nous n'avons pas eu à
avoir recours à notre potentiel
militaire je ne peux m'empêcher de vous
demander ces derniers mois comme nous le
savons il ya eu des troubles sur le
territoire de certains pays membres de
l'otan s'est notamment en biélorussie et
au kirghizstan à la frontière de
l'arménie dans la zone du conflit du
haut karabakh
les combats sont en cours le matériel
mais était le plus lourd et est employé
et les systèmes de défense antimissile
s-300 ont également été utilisés pour la
première fois comment le tess
réagit-elle as
concernant le conflit du haut karabagh
l'hôtesse et a été la première
organisation internationale à réagir à
l'intensification du conflit et au
déclenchement des hostilités
nous nous sommes dit très préoccupé par
l'aggravation de la situation et avons
appelé les parties à un cessez-le-feu
immédiat et à un retour au processus de
négociations sous les auspices des
coprésidents du groupe de minsk de
l'osce voilà quand à notre réaction face
aux événements du haut karabagh tous les
pays membres de l'hôtesse et ont réagi
de la même manière
concernant les événements en biélorussie
l'aggravation de la crise politique
il y a également eu une réaction
appropriée nous ne sommes pas restés
silencieux
bien sûr nous suivons de près ce qui se
passe dans tous nos pays
les événements ont été évalués notre
position est la suivante on considère
cela comme une affaire purement interne
à la biélorussie le pays à toutes les
possibilités de faire face à ses
problèmes par lui même sans aucune
ingérence extérieure
bien sûr on a clairement affirmé
notamment en la personne de l'actuel
président du conseil de sécurité
collective de l'eau tsc il s'agit là du
président de la fédération de russie
vladimir poutine que l'organisation
était prête à apporter tout le soutien
dont la république aurait besoin
en réponse à l'activité croissante de
l'otan aux frontières ouest de notre
bloc des actions adéquates ont également
été entreprises en biélorussie dans le
cadre d'exercices
nous avons aussi fait preuve de notre
volonté de mettre en oeuvre d'autres
mesures si nécessaire et cela n'a pas
été nécessaire
il en est de même aujourd'hui vous
connaissez la déclaration de vladimir
poutine selon laquelle des réserves
appropriées avaient été créés et pouvait
le cas échéant être utilisé rien de tout
cela n'a été nécessaire la situation
n'exige
plus de réaction de l'otan et quant aux
événements au kirghizstan
l'approché si müller l'approché là même
le pays traverse une période difficile
nous espérons vivement que la situation
se stabilisera y passera à des
considérations juridiques et d'ailleurs
nous en avons aussi parlé lors de la
table ronde il a été notamment mentionné
que l'hôtesse séjour est si nécessaire
son rôle de médiateur
mais bien sûr tout dépend de ce dont on
a besoin et de ce que veut le peuple
kirghize claude à quelles sont les
conditions pour que l'hôtesse et se voit
contrainte intervenir il existe deux
types de situations critiques
la première est qu'en les menaces pesant
sur la sécurité la stabilité et
l'intégrité d'un état membre de
l'hôtesse et se concrétise dans ce cas
celui ci est en droit de s'adresser à
l'hôtel c est le mécanisme de
consultations interétatiques y compris
des consultations d'urgence se met en
place et ont fourni une assistance et un
soutien nécessaire à cet état en
fonction de sa demande
blessé le second cas de figure concerne
les agressions militaires
elles sont toujours considérées comme
agression envers tous les états membres
à la demande du pays qui fait l'objet
d'une telle agression nous fournissons
immédiatement toute aide nécessaire y
compris militaires c'est dans ce type de
situation que tous les mécanismes de
soutien de l'eau tsc se mettent en
oeuvre vu la situation dans le haut
karabakh
je ne peux pas éviter la question si
l'azerbaïdjan frappe le territoire
arménien quelle sera la réponse de
l'hôtesse et je suis certain qu'une
telle situation n'aura pas lieu
pourquoi d'un côté parce que le
gouvernement azéri a dès le début
souligné
et vous en avez certainement entendu
parler
qu'il n'avait pas de réclamation
territoriale envers l'arménie qu'il
n'essayait pas de remettre en question
sa souveraineté ou son intégrité
c'est la première chose ensuite je pense
que du côté de l'azerbaïdjan
il y a suffisamment de bon sens et de
responsabilité vis-à-vis du peuple pour
ne pas entreprendre d'action qui
changerait immédiatement la situation
pour le moment il s'agit d'un certain
type de conflit et la communauté
internationale le prend en compte d'une
certaine manière mais s'ils
entreprennent une telle action alors
tout sera différent ni armée ni je pense
que ni l'azerbaïdjan ni l'armée ni ne
sont intéressés à l'idée de voir ce
conflit évolué en une guerre régionale
dont je n'envisage pas ici une telle
évolution
d'après vos et at-il un inconvénient que
l'azerbaïdjan ne fasse pas partie du
traité de sécurité collective
je pense que vous parler du fait que
l'azerbaïdjan a précédemment fait partie
du traité mais qu'il n'a pas prolongé
son adhésion en fait je ne ferai pas de
lien entre la non prolongation du traité
par l'azerbaïdjan et les événements en
cours
cette année nous avons aussi l'exemple
de l'ouzbékistan qui faisait partie du
traité mais s'en est retirée par la
suite ce n'était pas pour avoir les
mains libres mais pour d'autres raisons
qui leur sont propres
c'est pour cette raison que je ne vois
pas de rapport comment le tc considère
la participation de pays tiers au
conflit du haut-karabakh notamment celle
de la turquie et du sabotier
l'implication de nouvelles parties dans
le conflit n'aide pas à le résoudre
ainsi nous saluons la participation de
ceux qui font partie du groupe de minsk
de l'osce et eux et qu'ils agissent dans
un cadre défini
nous considérons la participation
d'autres pays comme contre-productive
y compris celle de la turquie 17h06 la
turquie agi dans le cadre prescrit par
le groupe de minsk de l'osce et e
elle en a pleinement le droit et c'est
si elles dépassent ce cadre nous la
condamnons
bien sûr dans ce cas ci les roses mais à
quel point la menace de l'arrivée des
combattants terroristes de syrie et de
libye dans la région de haut karabakh et
elle grave si elle se concrétise comment
le tc réagira-t-elle mazas et il est
difficile de juger pour le moment à quel
point ce mouvement vers la zone de
conflit de combattants est réel et
dangereux est impliqué visiblement ce
mouvement est en cours et des
combattants arrivent
évidemment cela n'aide pas à normaliser
les relations c'est un défi certains non
seulement pour les parties au conflit
mais également pour les autres ce qui
est bien
nous partons donc là dessus mais pour
l'instant il n'a pas été décidé de
prendre des mesures particulières pour
empêcher l'arrivée de combattants de
syrie et d'autres pays et une telle
éventualité n'est pas prise en compte
il faut suivre la situation de près et
voir ce qu'il se passe là-bas réellement
mais je le répète il s'agit de toute
évidence d'un défi certains pour nous
tous
[Musique]
cette menace existe-t-elle pour des pays
en particulier des pays de la région
l'arménie la géorgie la russie puisque
sa frontière n'est pas loin ou s'agit-il
d'une menace pour la sécurité collective
des pays signataires du traité
cette menace doit être considérée comme
une menace commune bien sûr comme c'est
le cas avec les menaces terroristes qui
sont communes à tous et pour lesquels
les frontières n'existent pas que nous
pouvons éliminer ou minimiser ces
menaces qu ensemble
c'est ainsi qu'il faut considérer cette
situation suivant les événements dans
les pays de l'ex urss dans le cadre de
le décès a pu remarquer vous une
progression du sentiment national quel
rôle cela a joué dans de récents
troubles y compris en biélorussie une
montée du sentiment national je pense
qu'on peut en parler
concernant tous nos pays membres si on
comprend ce terme est ce comme l'intérêt
pour son histoire sa culture son
identité et l' envie de s'identifier en
tant que nation nous remarque cela dans
tous nos pays membres
l'initiateur rogne il n'ya en principe
aucun mal à cela
et si cela dépasse un certain cadre s'il
n'y a plus de tolérance culturelle
ethnique ou religieuse c'est une toute
autre situation mais nous ne constatons
pas d'évolution aberrante ni de menaces
qu'ils puissent en découler il y a donc
une montée du sentiment national dans
tous les pays y compris en biélorussie
[Musique]
l'intérêt du peuple biélorusse pour son
identité nationale
la question du qui sommes-nous existait
bien sûr bien auparavant
c'est normal dire que cela a influencé
de manière négative la récente crise
politique
non je ne vois pas le rapport la montée
du sentiment national peut engendrer un
besoin de leaders de symboles et il
arrive que les nazis contre qui le monde
entier s'est battu joue ce rôle
l'intérêt pour sa propre identité et le
nazisme ou plutôt le néonazisme
aujourd'hui son fils y ait des mesures
sont-elles prises par le tc et ses
membres ayant vécu le nazisme pour
empêcher la réapparition de tels
symboles mais la poste doit partir ça y
est
parce que les chignons ta question je
pense qu'il y à des néo nazis donc tout
aux états membres
ils sont très peu nombreux en vérité
surtout en biélorussie un pays qui a
dans ses gènes la haine du nazisme et de
son idéologie notamment à tony cotte
donc dire qu'il joue un rôle dans la
politique moderne et la vie publique
serait une exagération bouteille
il n'y a pas de rapport entre le
sentiment national et le danger néo
nazis
en même temps on ne peut pas négliger le
danger d'une résurgence du nazisme ni de
sa popularisation plus assez nous menons
un certain travail y compris dans le
cadre de l'hôtel c'est un travail qui
est lié à la mémoire de la grande guerre
patriotique des efforts qui visent à
empêcher la falsification de l'histoire
à lutter contre la popularisation du
nazisme
nous y travaillons et cette année un
programme particulier a été dressé et
comprenant tout un ensemble de mesures
non seulement commémorative mais
également d'autres destinées à préserver
la vérité historique concernant cette
guerre vous considérez donc ces risques
existent il existe toujours je pense on
ne peut pas se permettre de se reposer
sur ses lauriers
[Musique]
j'ai dit dès le début qu'il y avait des
partisans du nazisme dans tous les pays
ils représentent une minorité absolue
mais ils existent il faut les prendre en
compte dans notre travail nous avons en
outre évoqué la remise en question du
déroulement de la grande guerre
patriotique
pourquoi est ce encore plus dangereux
non seulement parce que l'exploit des
générations précédentes et remis en
question mais aussi parce qu'un s'ils se
mettent en place des conditions pour
changer l'ordre mondial
instauré par les états vainqueur de la
seconde guerre mondiale je pense que
tout cela est interdépendant de manière
il faut comprendre cela notre
organisation consacre beaucoup
d'attention à ce que la vérité
historique de cette guerre soit défendu
pour que l'histoire ne puisse être
falsifiés et que le nazisme ne gagne pas
en popularité
face à ce tollé et propose à ses
danseuses au regard de ce que vous avez
dit et dans les conditions actuelles il
semble indispensable de développer un
système de sécurité commun de quelle
manière cela fonctionne-t-il au sein de
l'hôte et 18 ans ont passé depuis la
création de l'organisation
et on voit bien sûr que la situation
change le système même de l'hôtesse
échange bien si tim hudak modifie les
priorités dans notre travail
si au début on était focalisée sur les
menaces militaires se sont aujourd'hui
d'autres types de menaces qui surgissent
comme le terrorisme la drogue
la migration clandestine tout cela est
interdépendant et nous développons en ce
moment une branche chargée de ce genre
de menaces beauté chasseneuil nous
mettons l'accent plutôt sûr cela à
l'heure actuelle les forces adéquates
ont été réunis et nous menons des
opérations antiterroristes concrètes en
permanence contre les menaces
terroristes le mercenariat et les
menaces informatiques
voilà le changement qui a lieu si on
parle de la sécurité tous les membres de
lo tc contribue-t-il de la même manière
vous y at il un leader
chaque pays contribuent mais bien sûr
les moyens ne sont pas les mêmes il faut
admettre que la fédération de russie
joue un rôle très important dans notre
organisation la chaleur ça va être assez
serré où cetto est patente étant donné
son potentiel et les moyens qu'elle a à
sa disposition
il serait juste de dire qu'elle joue un
rôle très importante mais tous les pays
contribuent à nos activités
j'occupe ce poste depuis sept mois et je
suis allé dans tous les pays membres
tout le monde est très intéressé à
l'idée de renforcer l'organisation
c'était pâques en paroles mais en actes
sont prêts à participer car ils
comprennent que c'est nécessaire pour
garantir la sécurité commune il peut y
avoir des différends entre états des
questions à résoudre mais la sécurité
commune reste une priorité
quel est le rôle des manoeuvres
conjointes de l'hôte et c'est dans ce
contexte les manoeuvres constitue la
préparation ultime des armées y compris
des forces conjointes que nous avons
formés c'est pour cela que nous
réalisons de tels exercices ils varient
et ont lieu tous les ans malheureusement
cette année à cause de la pandémie et
malgré tous nos efforts nous avons dû
reporter certains exercices à l'année
prochaine
ces entretiens connus mais nous
envisageons quelques-uns d'ici la fin de
l'année y compris l'exercice prévu pour
le tc un visage tel un élargissement à
l'avenir
y at il des obstacles à cela nous sommes
ouverts aux pays amis qui partagent les
normes de notre charte du traité de
sécurité collective d'un certain temps
ils ont la possibilité d'adhérer à
l'hôtel c'est avec l'accord de tous les
états membres bien sûr si on prend par
exemple l'azerbaïdjan et l'ouzbékistan
qui ont fait partie de l'eau tc mais ont
quitté l'organisation
je n'ai pas fini
ces décisions sont prises avec l'accord
de tous les pays membres de l'otan et
nous comprenons que de telles décisions
sont très importantes très sérieuse et
je ne mettrai pas à l'ordre du jour un
élargissement de notre bloc mais plutôt
un élargissement de bon voisinage à
travers des statut d'observateur et de
partenaires de l'organisation
nous avons signé des accords et nous
nous attendons à ce que le processus de
ratification de ces accords qui entérine
juridiquement les statut d'observateur
ou de partenaires de l'organisation ait
lieu cette année
grâce à cela nous prévoyons de mettre en
place un cercle de bon voisinage cercle
alice est d'origine
comment une telle extension pourrait
affecter l'action de l'atc face aux
menaces et notamment face aux menaces
extérieures expliqué son potentiel
aujourd'hui pour faire face à de telles
menaces
la décision d'élargir l'organisation est
très sérieuse nécessite une évaluation
équilibrée de la part de tous les états
membres afin que cela ne nuise pas à
l'organisation que cela ne la
compromettre par conséquent s'il s'agit
de pays qui partagent notre charte les
normes de notre accord et qui se montre
amicaux envers nous tous la décision
sera positive
de telles décisions ne feront que
renforcer l'organisation
il en va de même pour tous le cercle de
pays observateur et partenaires de
l'ôter est un monsieur z
merci beaucoup pour ces réponses
détaillées et pour avoir trouvé le temps
de répondre à nos questions chers
téléspectateurs merci pour votre
attention et à bientôt mercier vous
[Musique]